this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 27 sitting here with Echo Charles
sometimes known as Echo Charlie sure
hell yeah so the last one of these that
we did we were talking about this
this psychological study called the
monster study
which is really messed up and also kind
of shows the kind of influence you can
have over another human being especially
a young malleable human being but then
we were talking to Hicks and Gracie the
other day on the dockle podcast and um
he was talking about how he how he
overcame
claustrophobia he went into the Hixson
Vegito
and
I I know I kind of wanted to say
something during the podcast but it
would have sidetracked the podcast let's
face it we could add a 45 minute give
you one hour discussion about your
experience of claustrophobia yeah
no I figured I made a little note next
time we get on here we could talk about
your experiences with claustrophobia
which were pretty gnarly and then you
got over it kind of I believe yeah where
are you at what was it like what did it
feel like you and I used to train yeah
and you sometimes
would tap out from not a submission but
just from claustrophobia yes
well yeah I had a guy he wanted my
platoons
and he would we'd roll and I'd roll with
everybody so by the time he would show
up because I'd roll with people
sequentially hey you come if you know 5
15 you come at 5 30 Whatever by the time
this guy showed up I would be you know
sweaty and he would he only probably
rolled with me three times because after
that he just didn't want to do Jiu Jitsu
anymore but he
I remember him just getting so angry you
know I'm a cross side or I'll mount it
or something and he's just joking he's
tapping just like just get off me yeah
get on like walking around the mat angry
yeah you know what I'm saying and it was
claustrophobia yeah but he expressed it
through anger and and and frustration
but just really just anger he hated it
yeah
what was your feeling like
well funny asses because I do think
about it because it you know like when
you see on the movies or whatever or you
hear about people when they have it
really bad like they can't go in an
elevator even or like in a crowded space
or whatever where it's not it's not even
that not that at all
um it was more the idea that I can't
like do I can't get out of here like I
can't move I can get out of this
tight like space yeah well this is
reminding me of Admiral Maguire's story
about being in the
torpedo tube yeah with water in there
and a rig and three other guys yeah 21
inch circle by the way yeah I saw a
comment somebody read that and said 21
inch circle that's the size of echo
Charles's arms
yeah man that uh so that's a little
that's a little tube you're in yeah and
so even that yeah I'd feel it with the
water and stuff yeah that's crazy here's
the thing that would always help though
is if I if I had something else on my
mind like if I was doing something like
I've had a job to do or whatever then it
like takes it away fully so the times
where I felt it and I really had to like
okay so Jiu Jitsu right where it was
because you really like Jiu Jitsu yes
you really like jiu jitsu
everything but that so you kind of had
to force yourself to get over that yeah
and you there was only a handful of
people that I felt it with though and
you because your side mount is freaking
is not only heavy because you put a
bunch of extras on your side control
like your heaviness you know like what
you walk around in what 230 or whatever
you don't feel like two thirds like I've
had guys who's 300 pounds that their
side control is not that like hard you
know just your regular side control not
the kind like you're trying to put
elbows or anything like that just
regular resting side control whatever
um it's like heavy it was less about the
physical feeling it was more about the
mental feeling because
if let's say I'm going with like a
really a new Jiu Jitsu guy and he goes
side Mountain he's 270 pounds
I know like when it's time I can get out
of here if I make it a point like I'm
gonna get out I can get out so whatever
but with you it's not like that so I can
be like I can my life can depend on it
and I probably won't get out of here so
and then not to mention I'm probably
tired or or we'll say I'm not full
energy right um little short on breath a
little short on breath like all that
thing and you put it all together
it's like oh so if I feel like hey I'm
working on a very specific technique to
get out of sight control it won't affect
me it's weird because I'll be trying to
work on that technique
but if it fails a couple of times then
I'm just left with the side control and
I'm like dang yeah and then I'll feel it
for sure but it has a lot to do with two
uh you're kind of over it now though
aren't you I'm over yeah for sure 100
. I haven't felt to put that to the test
in the near future yeah if and here's
the thing too here's a weird thing it's
also like so remember there was a time
where you thought I wasn't over it or
you maybe thought I wasn't you wanted to
put it to the test and then you did this
thing you went psychotron you put your
feet up on the wall to make it extra
heavy and I was like oh I feel it
physically but I didn't feel it mentally
okay almost like the movie you're cured
I felt like the more you're trying to do
it to me and I know you're trying to
make me claustrophobic the less it works
I feel like if you're just like if
you're just like okay you got the
position and let me just hold it here to
set up this or set up that I'm like man
there's no escape on this thing because
you're dedicated to the site control for
the for the personal purpose of having
the side control for a reason and then I
have no choice because you're gonna hold
it
you know what it might be though when
you put your feet up on the wall and
you're like yeah Echo [__] side
control side control side mount no you
got determined yeah like it's like a me
against you now so I get to yeah it's
like I have another job to do but um
yeah I don't have it anymore I don't
think I feel like what you have to do
the part that I think is psychological
is if you start thinking about it if
you're thinking about the fact that you
can't move there's some parable about
your this Village and there's a pot in
the village and if you can stir the pot
through the night without thinking about
and they tell you what you're not
allowed to think about then through the
night it'll turn to gold and so they
tell whatever the thing is they're not
supposed to be you know don't think
about the waterfall
if you think about the waterfall it
won't turn into gold and so everyone
goes out there they're stir in the pot
and they think about the waterfall and
they don't get the gold but then someone
shows up and they say hey just turn to
uh stir this pot all night they don't
tell them what to not think about
and then they just go in there and they
start they're not paying attention to it
right just anything like anything's like
that right if you don't notice someone
yeah if someone says hey is that noise
bothering you I wasn't even now I can
hear it now I couldn't hear it before
now it's bothering me yeah so you got to
learn how to shut that part of your
brain off and just just fixate on other
things not get focused on the fact that
you can't move your arms yeah and that
there's a waterfall somewhere he Hixson
brought up a good point though which
I was impressed that he had this mindset
so early where he was like he felt the
claustrophobia from the headlock and he
yeah and then he goes and like works on
it yeah in this like crazy way at
however 12 years old or something like
that I'm like like 12 usually at 12
you're like I'm never doing that again
I'm gonna avoid the headlock next time
you know sure but I feel like when
you're when I am more like in shape and
breathing
helps and stuff like that and then the
more you you know the more I roll with
you the more yeah the less
claustrophobia I'm gonna feel
right on
I just wanted to bring that up
yeah let's roll what do you got for Q a
I've got some interesting q a hey Jocko
and Echo I'm a huge fan of podcast I
appreciate everything that you guys are
doing since listen I went from being a
high school dropout to maintaining a 4.0
GPA in all my college classes while
working full-time in training at least
three days a week in Jiu Jitsu I've
dreamed to pursue a military I have
dreams to pursue the military once I
complete my associate's degree and I
cannot thank you enough for the
motivation and mentorship that I've
received from the podcast with all that
being said I feel I'm lacking a strong
male figure in my life I'm a married 21
year old female
my biological father isn't in the
picture my husband is paramilitary and
struggles deeply with depression he's a
very mentally unstable and struggles
with wanting to end his life often I
feel like I don't have a strong male
figure to lean on when I need help or
advice I truly want I truly want what
Dakota Meyer spoke of having with you
someone I know I can call and trust my
question is how do I find a fatherly
figure as an adult is this something I
should let happen organically through
Jiu Jitsu or in the future through the
military
do you think this is something that I
should just forget and move on from
instead if it's something I should
pursue actively what does that look like
tangibly thank you for all you do
awesome
um so here's what I think of mentors and
I I have talked about this before you've
got to kind of build your own mentors in
life and the chances that you have
someone that swoops down to Mentor you
the chances of that happening
in a in a really overt way hi Jocko how
you doing I want to be your Mentor well
great you have experience in the things
that I've always wanted to do so you're
going to be a good Mentor
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us strengthen
this Legion of Troopers that are in the
game with us so thank you it's Jocko
underground.com it cost eight dollars
and 18 cents a month and if you can't
afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance at
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground